hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Doctor Strange spoilery review
so if you haven't seen the movie there
will be spoilers but Earth has wizards
now so let's go Thor has that great line
at the end where he kind of becomes the
proxy for the audience where he's like
so Earth has wizards now what what's
going on
but then sees the beer mug refill itself
and decides the Doctor Strange is
totally cool so he's kind of like the
proxy for the audience like we're all
looking at this going this is kind of
weird but okay okay yeah this is cool
this is totally cool so I will say
Doctor Strange as a solo origin story is
somewhere near the top of all the Marvel
solo films so far now like I still feel
like some of the best Marvel movies are
not the origin story movies like usually
it's like the second movie Captain
America Winter Soldier still one of the
best Marvel movies so far so Doctor
Strange isn't better than Winter Soldier
but that's just because it falls into a
lot of the traps of traditional Marvel
films and superhero films in general
where you have a lot of really awesome
performances but not really enough time
to do all the characters justice so
usually character development is where
big blockbuster movies fall down so you
have an underdeveloped villain but you
have a lot of great setup for chiwetel
ejiofor Baron Mordo so that they can do
their Winter Soldier in their next movie
so that's why I think the next Doctor
Strange movie will be an even better
movie early sets potential to be a
better movie but the film itself you
know with the way it warps reality the
way they use magic the way they
visualize it is a big push in a new
direction for Marvel so I give them big
big bonus points for trying something
completely different
even if they do have some of the same
trappings of Marvel films like you don't
really understand what Casilla is plan
is if you're not a comic-book person
like the minute they start talking about
the Dark Dimension you see the eye of
agamotto and he warps time with it with
the Apple you know exactly what's going
on but if you're not a comic book person
you might not make those connections so
your enjoyment of the movie hinges more
on the actors performances which all are
great Maz mickelson amazing actor told
swinton amazing actress benedict
cumberbatch obviously great even rachel
mcadams in her small role is really good
too but I just felt like a lot of the
missing scenes that helped develop
casillases character kept it from being
an a-plus movie so I gave the movie you
know operating by itself like just you
know taking it as it is in a - but is a
comic-book person myself you know just
like combing for Easter eggs
it was a definite a especially for the
experience of the roller-coaster ride
through the Marvel magical you know
mystical universe and you may have
recognized like a little bit of Harry
Potter in there with the way they tried
to give some humor to the cloak of
levitation like the wand chooses the
wizard the artifact chooses the wizard
so I feel like all that stuff totally
worked you know they had a couple nice
well-timed jokes there were three really
hilarious moments one the cloak of
levitation itself like the way they gave
it personality and in the scenes that it
was in to the Wong Beyonce joke and then
three masts Mickelson's mister dr.
moment I felt like he was a lot funnier
as Doctor Strange than he was as Stephen
strange like the movie came alive when
he became Doctor Strange or when he was
in the process of becoming Doctor
Strange but I think that was by design
it was meant to be that way like Kevin
Feige said that the original Iron Man
movie you know very similar to the arc
the Doctor Strange has in the comics
where like an doctor becomes the
sorcerer supreme who's still kind of an
so they wanted to change that a
little bit so they weren't doing like
the exact carbon copy of that first Iron
Man movie so that is why early in the
film after he has his accident he turns
into a super like they almost
make him unlikable with the way he
pushes Rachel McAdams character away you
have to imagine like this would be like
Tony Stark throwing a book or something
at Pepper Potts so like they wanted to
take Doctor Strange all the way to the
bottom of human existence so that they
could bring him all the way back up it
was like a much bigger journey back up
to the top so I felt like that was
successful even if he's not quite as
charismatic as Robert Downey jr. but
that you know that just like the actors
performance and a lot of that is built
into the character dr. strange very
different character from Tony Stark
doctors
range is more of like this bookish
librarian type like the way he just
blows through stacks and stacks of books
Tony Stark is also very brilliant but
how often do you see him sitting there
reading books they definitely made an
effort to give him this dry sense of
humor it'll be interesting to see how he
you know reacts when he meets the other
Avengers because Tony Stark is like mr.
quip like he always has some funny way
to make light of the situation in doctor
strangest thing is is that he tries to
make a joke that almost intentionally
falls flat in the comedy is in the
awkwardness the non reaction that he
gets from people like nothing you know
Beyonce Adele like that was what they
were trying to do with that single name
montage and Wong is just sitting there
but I don't think it ever quite got to
be as funny as they like ant-man
or an Iron Man movie a man was one of
those like really small but also kind of
big movies Doctor Strange is also like a
really big small movie you know just
because of the things that they're
dealing with Dormammu
I've come to bargain you know yet
another villain that they kind of brush
over but if you're a comic book person
you know exactly what's going on
so you just freak out you're like oh my
god they're finally doing this it's
amazing
but if visually the movie isn't a-plus
you know like I said that you know
villain under development kind of heard
it just a little bit which I think
largely will not be an issue in the
sequel because you already have Baron
Mordo you know exactly where he's coming
from very clearly he will be the Winter
Soldier of the next movie but it's a
great first step into the mystic Artes
you'll see a lot more of this in the
Marvel Universe during phase 3 very
clearly Doctor Strange is going to be
guest starring in Thor Ragnarok probably
other movies too besides Avengers
infinity war that's just the big one but
even if things like the humor didn't
quite land that I totally forgave them
that for the other stuff they were doing
like you hear Living Tribunal shoutouts
so you're just like oh my god so there
were a lot of moments like that where
you kind of get an idea for what's
coming in how the way they visually did
this is going to color the other phase
three phase four movies and obviously
I'm going to be doing an Easter Egg
video that'll
explain all that there were a ton of
Easter eggs but the thing all tease you
with going into that is Kevin Feige
talking about how they're going to be
mixing really small character-based
team-up movies going forward along with
like the big Avengers huge movies so
what does that mean it just means that
every single sequel is not going to be
like a big beam of light in the sky type
of movie where there's some intangible
unknowable threat that is the villain of
the movie like I think they saw a Winter
Soldier how well that worked because of
the character dynamics in there trying
to do more movies like that where it's
not like constantly world ending stakes
like Civil War wasn't like a world
ending movie just because Thor wasn't
there Hulk wasn't there nobody was
threatening the earth it was just friend
on friend violence so Feige is telling
us that there's going to be more movies
like that mixed with the big Avengers
films they'll still be doing the huge
Avengers films but they recognize that
they just can't keep getting bigger and
bigger with every film like that's
usually where you fail is when you try
to make films bigger and bigger and
bigger they just start to fall apart
from the inside so you guys can let me
know like what did you think of Doctor
Strange and remember this is a spoilery
review so feel you know feel free to go
crazy with spoilers in the comments
stuff you like stuff you didn't like
stuff you're super hype about and just
because people are still seeing the
movie I'll probably wait til Saturday to
do my Easter Egg video but if you
haven't seen it yet and you decided to
watch this video anyway I'd recommend
you go see it in 3d just because of the
way they warp space that actually looks
pretty cool they have a cool explanation
for how that works too it's not
something that everyone can do no matter
what the speaking of Marvel magic there
is an infamous Iron Man comic book video
that I've been wanting to do that I
haven't been able to get out there's
also some legends of tomorrow I'll be
doing and then obviously you know more
Avengers Post Doctor Strange Thor
Ragnarok bigger Marvel Universe so I'll
try to post that through the rest of the
weekend well you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for like that
big behind-the-scenes tour Ragnarok
video and you can click here to learn
how you know executive in fighting
almost cost civil war
spider-man as well as Robert Downey jr.
so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight there are two types of
things in the universe